as someone who grew up watching an
obscene amount of movies and TV shows
there are several that I've always stuck
with me
one of those being Gilmer de todos 2006
fantasy drama Pan's Labyrinth and today
we'll be focusing on one character in
particular now anyone who has seen any
of the toros movies who know that they
are filled of unique and strange-looking
creatures that are quite often
terrifying and this is certainly the
case for Pan's Labyrinth in fact looking
back at it now the movie itself has some
quite dark and underlying themes that
aren't exactly suitable for children the
creature that we'll be covering in
today's video is the pale man a creature
that myself and I'm sure many others can
attribute quite a few sleepless nights
to the Power Man is an ancient child
devouring demon like creature that our
protagonist Ophelia encounters during
her quest she's sent to retrieve a
dagger from the pale man's lair but
before she embarks on her journey she is
warned by the faun and fairies assist in
her that the monster she will encounter
devours children Afilias still
determined to complete her quest travels
to the creatures lair and we first
encounter him sitting motionless at his
dining table as his name would suggest
he skin was extremely pale and wrinkled
with an elastic quality he appeared as a
rather grotesque humanoid monster with
long black claws two nostrils we'd
expect his nose to be and no sockets for
his eyes as they would instead be placed
into the palm of his hand looking around
it becomes very apparent that a Fela is
not the first child to stumble upon the
pale man's layer as we see piles of
children's shoes almost being kept as
trophies this may also indicate that the
Monster eats its victims entirely as we
see no bones of human remains left there
are numerous paintings on the walls and
the ceilings showing the demon devouring
children these children are very clearly
pleading and begging for mercy which
shows us that the pale man may have no
trace of humanity left we don't actually
know a great deal about the pale man's
abilities and powers but he does appear
to be extremely old being able to enter
a deep slumber for hundreds of years if
not more until he's awakened by his name
victim we can then assume that along
with his great strength he may also
possess immortality there are a couple
of things that allude to the pale man
being capable of magical sorcery
despite being in a deep slumber the food
on his table appears to show no sign of
rotten decay now this could be some kind
of spell or enchantment designed to
trick the children and enter his lair if
we take a look at his lair itself there
is no entrance or exit so he must have
some way of luring children into his
lair in the first place
not wanting to stick around much longer
philia lets out her fairy companions who
assist her and find in the dagger but as
Ophelia is about to leave she falls
victim to the temptation of the banquet
before her despite being adamantly
warned by the fairies she ignores them
picking up and eaten a grape this
appeared to immediately break the
Pearlman slumber as we see him place an
eye in each one of his palms in quite a
disturbing and terrifying scene a philia
still occupied by the food Felson notice
that the Perelman has awoken and when
she eventually does the fairies attempt
to distract him with two of them being
mercilessly devoured using the fairies
distraction she races back to the
entrance that she created being closely
pursued by the pale man who in this
moment shows us that his mobility may in
fact be his only weakness resembling a
decrepit old man when chasing the philia
through the hallways seen the interest
as she previously created disappeared
due to her taking too long
Buffy Lea takes a piece of chalk and is
able to draw a new exit just above her
outside of the reach of the pale man and
she's able to barely escape
when he was asked about the influences
of the pale man datura does mention the
painting by Francisco Goya of Saturn or
Cronus devouring his own children to be
quite an inspiration and if we take a
look at the paintings on the walls and
the ceilings of the pale man's layer
they are quite reminiscent of Goya's
work the pale man's mythological
influences do stretch beyond Greek and
Roman myth all the way to Japan and the
yokai known as a tenor me an elderly
looking man with no face and an eyeball
in each palm the tenor major diet is
also quite similar to the pal man
consistent of human bones fresh from the
body the pearl man is a great example of
del Toro's ability to create a visually
striking creatures and monsters that are
so terrifying because they rarely
resemble anything we've seen before if
you've never seen Pan's Labyrinth before
then I highly recommend that you do and
if you have any thoughts on a pal man or
Pan's Labyrinth in general and feel free
to share them with me in the comments
below as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained